welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and we have a whole
host of new DC updates to talk about
every couple of days the company seems
to be coming out with something new and
throughout this video we'll be going
over the fandom event the secret movies
that have been teased they're the Ray
Fisher Justice League drama and a lot
more there might be some spoilers here
so if you don't anything ruined about
the upcoming events then I highly
recommend that you turn off now make
sure you subscribe to the channel for
videos like this every day
and please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy
the content without the way thank you
for clicking this and let's get into our
DC breakdown okay so in the wake of the
pandemic comic book companies have had
to think outside of the box over how
they're gonna host their conventions
this year and DC have really outdone
themselves in order to make sure that
fans of the company have fun whilst the
world falls apart they're throwing a
convention called DC fandom which will
be a 24-hour online only event that
showcases their upcoming movies shows
and games in the center is the Hall of
Heroes and this is where you will enter
meteor mates and get to go out into the
other halls to see the exclusive panels
and trailers from all the upcoming DC
movies now firstly is the DC watch verse
which will allow you to become a virtual
audience member DC are planning on
showing hours of content including
panels and exclusive screenings they'll
also be showing never-before-seen
footage across their movies TVs and
games I imagine that this will feature
footage from the Batman and this might
be where we get a glimpse at what the
creative team did on the movie before
things shut down Wonder Woman 84 is
right around the corner as is Suicide
Squad which has completed filming thus I
would imagine that we also get to see
footage from both of them including a
world exclusive look at the latter it's
also likely that we'll get an
announcement on exactly what is
happening with the flash movie and
Michael Keaton Keaton is apparently in
talks to appear in the film and it was
thought that things were going to be
officially announced at fan dome before
the news leak last week from The Wrap so
plenty of things to get excited over
before the event in August it's also
rumored that we'll be getting an
announcement of the games at WB Montreal
and Rocksteady have been working on
this includes a Suicide Squad game in
which you may be fighting the Justice
League bans have drawn this conclusion
because recently Warner Brothers
registered the domains Suicide Squad
game comm and Suicide Squad killer
Justice League comm the other game is
apparently called Gotham Knights and
this will be a continuation of the
Arkham franchise similar to shadow of
Mordor the game will reportedly contain
a Nemesis system that sees the
bat-family gaining rivalries with
gangsters as well as corrupt police
members according to the comics Kidd the
game will contain the following elements
the bat family will be playable now this
was something that we saw in Arkham
Knight when you could play as a
Nightwing Robin and Batgirl
however hopefully it extends beyond that
and we can be ace the bat-hound the next
point says multiple factions in a
Nemesis system that includes the GCPD
this is of course very interesting as it
will require you to play both sides of
the law the final point says the owls
will be the main antagonists and what I
like about this is that it says one of
the main ones so we will be getting
other puns but yeah I'm definitely
interested in exploring the Owls I'm
guessing that this is set after Arkham
Knight and that the Joker will be dead
but it is possible that he could
resurrect him similar to how Batman and
Joker were in the Bloom and epilogue of
Scott Snyder's run as for the other
areas DC u-verse is going to feature
user-generated content such as fan art
cosplayers and a lot more DC kids verse
will have hours long family-friendly
content that will keep the little ones
busy whilst you check out the great
Snyder verse which is let's face it what
we all really care about now next is the
DC inside of us which will contain a
panel with DC CCO Jim Lee who'll be
going over the entire company's future
and what we can expect as fans lastly is
DC fun voice which will have some stuff
for comic book fans including how to
make DIY Wonder Woman armored Batmobile
kits and digital giveaways so you can
get exclusive content before anyone else
however I just want that DIY Wonder
Woman armor because I think I think I'd
look really good in it now on top of all
this the convention recently released a
new section on the mobile version of
their website that will allow fans to
ask a question about
big movie why this has got so many
people excited is because I'm there
there has been added to secret movies so
we do know that there are two projects
that were completely oblivious to that
will be talked about at the event I'm
really hoping that we get a Man of Steel
to announcement in some form or another
however with rumors being that Henry
will feature in smaller roles across the
universe rather than substantial ones I
really can't see it obviously I would
absolutely love to see it as a Man of
Steel is probably one of my favorite if
not my favorite DC EU movie however I'm
not sure at the moment but I guess time
will tell what I do think will happen is
that it's gonna be likely that the
movies we've sort of heard about being
in the works but not had out-and-out
confirmed and therefore they're still
technically secrets the usual suspects
for this are of course Black Adam which
we know is in development but haven't
really seen anything major in regards to
other than casting there's also the New
Gods film which will be written by Tom
King and feature Darkseid as Darkseid is
being brought to the Snyder cut I can't
see this one being one of the most
likely contenders as the studio will
likely want to promote this film off the
back of the upcoming Snyder Kurt Johnson
the script for the Green Lantern Corps
movie and there is a chance that another
Holly Quinn project involving Margot
Robbie could be dropped to whatever
these films are they'll be rubbing
shoulders with Aquaman the Batman flash
Shazam the Snyder cut the Suicide Squad
Wonder Woman 1984 and potentially even
any Watchmen announcement either way
there's a lot to look forward to and I
really can't wait to see what happens at
the event which is scheduled to drop on
August 22nd now before we get into the
rest of the video I just wanna let you
know we're giving away a free copy of
the MCU infinity Saga box set to one
random subscriber all you have to do to
being with a chance of winning is like
the video subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on the updates in
the comment section below the winners
gonna be chosen at random on the 15th of
July and the subtle be shipped out from
them to ever gets the prize so best of
luck to everyone who takes part
okay and finally we have a pretty crazy
statement coming from Ray Fischer in
regards to Joss Whedon and his work on
Justice League
Justice League of course had a troubled
production and after Snyder was either
taking off the project or he stepped
away Whedon stepped in to fill his shoes
and finish off the film it's rumored
that this required reshooting 70 percent
of the movie anything out major story
arcs rewriting large parts of the script
and generally changing the film so that
it was more in line with what Marvel
were doing and Warner Brothers clearly
picked him in order to try and follow in
their footsteps which ended up giving us
a film that felt completely different a
Man of Steel and BBS Suicide Squad was
also changed massively and though we
haven't heard too many negative things
about the behind-the-scenes process on
that film it's clear that Justice League
was a much more different story last
week ray Fisher aka cyborg dropped a
tweet which showed a video of him
praising Whedon and staying that he did
a great job in his handling of the
project Fisher said he'd like to take a
moment to forcefully retract every bit
of that statement we didn't really know
what that meant but yesterday Fisher
tweeted Joss Whedon onsets treatment of
the cast and crew of Justice League was
gross abusive unprofessional and
completely unacceptable he was enabled
in many ways by Geoff Johns and John
Berg accountability is more than
entertainment so a massive massive
statement to be making and it does paint
things out in a very negative light not
only does it make Whedon look bad but
also john berg production president and
geoff johns who was CCO of DC at the
time both exited their positions after
the poor performance of justice league
which was said to be a large factor in
the pair resigning DC comics in general
has been all over the place for the last
couple of years I think and rebirth
which was headed up by Jones
in my opinion started off well but it's
slowly sunk to the point that I don't
even really care about it anymore it
seems like this was the case on Justice
League Two and yet things that were
clearly not as fun as we were led to
believe now initially I was kind of like
well Whedon did have a lot of pressure
on his shoulders as he was brought in
last minute or film 7
percent of the movie and and try and
catch lightning in a bottle similar to
how he did with the Avengers there was
of course the Henry Cavill mustache
stuff and it's even rumored that the I
tried notice in the movie is from Whedon
who was trying to tell the audience he
did his best
however after thinking about it yeah all
that it still doesn't give anyone the
right to be abusive to people and
honestly when you see Fisher talk about
the movie it's kind of heartbreaking to
see what he went through
this was meant to be a big moment for
the actor and it looks like it was
pretty much ruined by a troubled
production schedule and a director that
was abusive towards him now there are
two sides to every story but for the
moment Whedon has remained silent on the
matter
however Alan Tudyk came out and spoke in
defense of him saying that he wasn't
there but he doesn't think that Whedon
would do it and can't imagine it again
though he wasn't there and doesn't know
what happened and I don't think you
should under value someone's experience
especially if you weren't there James
Gunn like this tweet and of course he's
working on Suicide Squad so yeah lots of
things potentially going on behind the
scenes at DC John burg however has not
remained quiet and on Wednesday he told
variety that it was categorically untrue
and that he did not enable any
unprofessional behavior he later went on
to say I remember Fischer being upset
that we wanted him to say Booya which is
a well-known saying of cyborg in the
animated series now this is something
that I've often heard but honestly it
just sounds like such a weird weird
thing that I'm personally not sure I
believe it obviously Fisher would know
this is the characters catchphrase and
it just seems like such a weird thing to
be angry over that I can't actually
imagine anyone getting angry over it
obviously I was in there but it doesn't
look like things were good I'm gonna
hold off giving my opinion on it until
things are fully out in the open as at
the moment there's no real evidence
either side to corroborate anything
however the fact that so many actors on
the project came forward to support
Snyder and Whedon silence does paint
things out as being a certain way which
doesn't look good it's a weird weird
situation in the lead-up to the Snyder
cut release and I guess we
we might find out in the next coming
weeks or we might never know now
obviously that's a lot of things to talk
about so make sure you leave your
thoughts in the comment section below if
you enjoyed this video then please give
it a thumbs up and make sure you check
out our latest DC video which is gonna
be linked at the end we go over all the
Michael Keaton rumors whether we think
Ben Affleck is returning or not and a
lot more if you want to support the
channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate you and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you only come chat to us after the
show either follow us at heavy spoilers
or click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with the channel
so hopefully we see over there very soon
and I hope you have a nice day at least
I hope someone out there watching this
video is having a nice day take care
much love
[Music]
you
[Music]